I'm fine I'm great yeah I'm doing really
well there Island deli needy she's
feeling great following news she
received a second kidney transplant you
know when a family member gives you a
second chance at life and it fails it
almost feels like it's your fault and
it's not when a second family member
someone you're supposed to look after
like a little brother wants to give you
a third chance at life it's scary I just
came back from Mexico and that was
really really nice um the good thing
about being stable health-wise is in
having an amazing significant other is
that now I'm able to travel more and I I
wasn't traveling for remember the last
time I took a vacation before this year
I think who I was 24 just turned 28 so I
had just been either working on my
health or working non-stop so it's
really nice to be able to do something
like that now the Modern Family star is
talking about her recent vacay with
boyfriend Wells Adams and get this she
says her character's pregnancy on the
hit ABC show is giving her a little bit
of baby fever yeah it's it's weird
especially we we filmed something where
I had not just like a one of those like
padded type of bellies that are weighted
but an actual prosthetic that we had
with a look like actually my belly
button I took like pictures of my skin
tone and like matched all of this stuff
to my belly and I think like down to
like a freckle here and so that was uh
so that was weird like you haven't get
like an ultrasound on your fake eye like
look down and I was like oh this is what
it would be like
[Music]